let's go to my friend jim trustee former
uh justice department prosecutor uh jim
you're so used to my simplistic
questions so help me with this let's say
the justice department exceeds uh you
know compelling judge to overturn this
so the masks have to be back on
then we have to put them back on in
planes that instantly becomes the case
yeah it's possible i mean look the only
ray of sunshine i'm getting from this so
far is that they have not moved to stay
the opinion you know a lot of times when
you note an appeal you also go to the
court or to the next court which would
be the 11th circuit here and you say
look we've got to stop this from taking
effect and they haven't done that yet i
take that as a mildly good sign there's
some possibility neil that this is what
you refer to as a protective notice of
appeal meaning hey we're just noting the
appeal we're going to sort it out and
figure it out before any sort of
briefing so i'm hoping that cooler heads
will kind of jump into the situation and
get us to a point where they withdraw
that appeal someday uh might be a fool's
errand that i'm thinking that way but
i'm at least hopeful that that's a
possibility
but you're right otherwise we could be
on this crazy seesaw and to answer your
question before the break neil i don't
think i'd bring a mask i think i might
bring a parachute i think that the
people on the plane will go nuts if they
get the reverse announcement during a
flight yeah i would wondered about that
you know
jim again i'm not a lawyer but i've
watched enough legal shows i think i
qualify so i want to ask you about
just common sense here why can't since
this is all originated from a cdc
recommendation
why can't the cdc go back and just say
well that's an option we think it's wise
for you to keep a mask on but that's up
to you end of story
yeah they absolutely could so your uh
your law and order episodes are paying
off i mean the issue in terms of this
ruling though is not really directly
about the wisdom
of wearing masks it's about the
authority of the cdc of a federal agency
to control individual conduct it's a
federalism notion and that's what the
white house is kind of losing track of
and a very muddled message it's hard to
know what they're doing but look they
also have something fundamentally
backwards here when you have an adverse
ruling to the department of justice it's
the lawyers that are going to make the
ultimate decisions about appeals it's
specifically the solicitor general looks
at the case looks at the reasoning
and says hey did they get this wrong is
there an injustice here or do we just
you know basically take it and let the
case be the law of the land
you don't just turn back to the client
in this case cdc and say gosh guys
you're so brilliant what do you want to
do they don't decide the appeal doj does
and so this is really backwards that
we're hearing these public comments
about well cdc thinks it's important and
they're all knowing and all powerful so
we're going to appeal it that's not the
way the process should be working that's
well explained you know jim you should
stick to this law thing you you seem to
show great promise there so uh
very one of these days very good singing
again my friend jim jurassic the former
doj
prosecutor hi i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now